Наступним зовнішньополітичним завданням України є початок переговорів щодо вступу до Шенгенської зони.
Про це заявила віце-прем'єрка з європейської та євроатлантичної інтеграції Іванна Клімпуш-Цинцадзе.
Раніше Президент Петро Порошенко оголосив, що його мета – це членство України у  Шенгені.
Приєднання до Шенгенської угоди за складністю можна прирівняти до отримання членства у Європейському Союзі, вважають експерти.
По-перше, країна-кандидат бере зобов'язання нести відповідальність за зовнішні кордони Шенгену.
Наразі, через військову агресію РФ, Україна не контролює більше 100 км свого кордону на сході.
Тому вона не може виконати цю умову.
По-друге, країни мають гарантувати
відсутність внутрішніх кордонів і перевірок - для вільного пересування громадян ЄС і країн Шенгенської зони.
По-третє, країна має дозволити поліції інших держав-членів Шенгену переслідувати злочинців
на своїй території, якщо виникне така необхідність. Наразі це не передбачено законодавством України.
Окрім того, члени Шенгену запроваджують єдині короткострокові Шенгенські візи і загальний
перелік країн, чиї громадяни потребують таку візу. Тобто у разі вступу до Шенгену
Україна мала б вимагати візи від громадян країн СНД, з якими у неї безвізовий режим.
Також, країни-претенденти повинні запровадити візову інформаційну систему, яка дає змогу
обмінюватись даними про власників короткострокових віз між шенгенськими країнами.
А також - Шенгенську інформаційну систему – яка є закритою і дозволяє поліцейським мати доступ до
бази даних розшукуваних або небажаних осіб та викрадених речей. Наразі у Києва нема доступу до цих механізмів.
В осяжному майбутньому шансів для вступу в Шенген немає.
Для приєдання до Шенгенської зони Україні слід буде адаптувати багато правил і законів Шенгену.
Для цього знадобиться щонайменше 15-20 років, вважають експерти. Окрім того є індивідуальні
вимоги до країни-претендента - у випадку України - це може бути закінчення конфлікту на Сході, подолання корупції тощо.